can't fit into a regular thing i didn't
know how to live like a person forever
well there's certain things that's why
we invited you because
we want you on the podcast yeah you're
one of the biggest guys but also i look
at you like a professor uh
just hear me out you look like a
professor yeah you're right i look up to
you and there's certain things that
people know that i don't know how to do
yeah and i want you to teach me like
what
well that's why we have the thing oh so
honestly i refuse to learn how to read
that type of clock you just want to do
it i don't know how to do it it's not a
read time i refuse yeah i'm well i'm
digital baby it's all digital it's all
digital for you are you what are you uh
dyslexic i'm not dyslexic no no
[Laughter]
we don't know at all you don't know we
don't know uncertainty i have a lot of
problems you know i could have a mood
disorder you have for sure adult adhd
yeah yeah i uh for sure i have um i
might have bipolar two maybe maybe we
maybe we don't know yet but there are
certain things that i refuse to learn
but i'm willing to learn now okay all
right and so
um the only one that i feel like can
teach me is you i will refuse for these
guys we've tried for years they've tried
for years i won't even listen what do
you mean it's like i know but that's why
okay to teach you how to read a class
i have a different things i don't know
about that's why you're here that's why
you're here okay let me hold it let me
hold it but isn't it just basically the
i don't know any of it man all right
it wasn't because there was a
vulnerability to the screaming ah
that is true it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't for help it wasn't defensive it
wasn't all right usually it's defensive
is this supposed to be like this it's
supposed to go ahead of it no like
that's bro it's ben
okay
all right so
let me just say something so what time
is it right now look at your digital
45. okay so put the little hand on the
four
i feel like i'm watching this one right
here yeah
no the little one that's one yeah put
that on the four uh-huh it should be a
pbs there you go now put the big one
hey would you say 445 yeah put it on the
nine
okay now you know why that's like that
do you know what that's like
why well well the four is
self-explanatory right
it's four o'clock right now the nine is
because do you see how the clock has
little dots all around it yeah there's
60
minutes in an hour
yeah i know
yeah
but by the way i know that okay good i
know that okay so so at what minute
so the so minute one starts at
at n at the twelve don't give up don't
give up i i i think i got it look minute
one starts at the twelve so if it's on
nine
what minute is that
all right so if there's 45 there you go
oh you should make a 4 45 that's four so
okay let's see this is three forty five
this is three thirty right
that's right
this is three
four yes let me test you all right turn
around
mark's voice yeah that's right yeah
it's [ __ ] easy
[Laughter]
are you digital for so long pretty
[ __ ] easy yeah
oh
so what time is it is that
wait so this is
wait why is this so this is at a yeah
here yeah so yeah
yes yes
and this is here yes 12 10. right
there you go
but what what happens if this is okay
what about this is here in the middle of
twelve and one well they won't be there
unless it's 12 30.
[Laughter]
what
that is 12
right yeah
50
yeah four yeah congratulations before
yeah
yeah digital is so much easier sure it's
so much easier will you can we admit
that yeah yeah yeah but like you know we
i didn't have digital i
[Music]
master
master class is for you
you guys
[Laughter]
guess who's on master class
so many people none other than our
friend and chef extraordinaire roy troy
choi